sa femme a couché le dimanche 27
novembre comment tu as été au courant le
20 novembre pardon je lui rajoute une
semaine
pour moi c'est cadeau non mais et donc
comment tu as été mis au courant de du
cambrioleur on nous a appelé parce que
la voisine a découvert la porte
fracturée voilà on nous a expliqué que
tout était saccagé à la maison on a été
très surpris dans la foulée on a eu la
police au téléphone qui nous a confirmé
l'effet et voilà donc tu as fait toutes
les démarches tu as été vous avez été au
commissariat quand vous êtes rentré au
départ on a tout de suite regardé la
localisation des appareils Apple on a
réussi à localiser quelques-uns des
appareils qui apparemment avait été
jetés dans une poubelle d'accord donc la
police a retrouvé une partie de de ces
appareils là donc dans la foulée nous on
a pris la route pour rentrer à la maison
on a tout de suite été au commissariat
enfin j'ai été au commissariat j'ai
déposé ma chérie et mon fils à l'abri et
donc j'ai été tout de suite pour le
véhicule pour le déclarer voler et qui
puisse être recherchés immédiatement
parce que c'est ce qui semblait être le
plus facile à retrouver dans les médias
alors on a tu as ensuite pu rentrer chez
toi et voir l'état de ta maison regarde
on a les images
tous les bijoux tous les cadeaux que
j'ai fait à ma femme ma chambre
de mon fils
je suis juste en colère la boîte
a fait toutes les lettres de mon fils et
tout ils ont pris tous les bijoux tout
tout le cadeau que je t'ai fait mon cœur
je peux pas toucher mais à mon avis il
reste rien du tout là
[Musique]
donc tu as tout filmé il tombe donc
comme tu as dit voler ta voiture donc
les bijoux voitures
tout ce qui pouvait trouver hein
donc tu vas porter plainte et
en même temps tu te dis que tu vas me
donner l'enquête toi-même comment ça se
passe ben quand je porte plainte je sors
du commissariat pour être très franche
je suis assez déçu je me rends compte
que ça va être très compliqué que les
choses vont prendre beaucoup trop de
temps et je me doute bien que dans ce
genre de situation le temps et je prends
notre faveur donc je me dis j'ai pas
envie d'attendre je n'ai pas envie
d'attendre que les choses se tassent et
que je sois déçu donc je décide de
prendre le devant alors il y en a alors
on va on va revenir dans un instant donc
tu prends les devants tu fais quoi
quand je sors du commissariat après la
plainte qui concerne le cambriolage
puisque la veille j'avais fait le dépôt
de plainte pour le véhicule ben je me
dis les choses vont pas bouger donc je
décide de partir à la recherche du
véhicule volé et je me rappelle que les
ordinateurs et téléphone ont été
retrouvés dans une poubelle en bas d'une
cité là où on vit à proximité de là où
on vit et je me dis il y a de grandes
chances pour que le véhicule soit pas
loin d'accord si on n'a pas de chance
parce que c'est des professionnels la
voiture est déjà partie loin si on a un
peu de chance peut-être qu'elle est
garée au fond d'un parking dans une cave
ou alors simplement quelque part donc je
décide de partir et je tourne avec ma
voiture
sans vraiment être certaines de ce que
j'allais trouver mais par chance et ben
je tombe dessus alors tu tombes sur la
voiture elle est il y avait quoi la
voiture a été en bon état il y a rien
elle était garée le plus normalement du
monde donc là tu fais quoi ben je suis
franchement je suis en folie grosse
grosse montée d'adrénaline parce que je
m'attendais pas à la retrouver la vérité
j'étais pleine d'espoir fin de colère
mais j'étais pas sûr de ce que j'allais
trouver donc ce que je fais c'est que
j'appelle la police le réflexe
pour être très franc maintenant avec un
peu de recul je l'aurais pas fait comme
ça
et donc arrive là-bas voilà ils arrivent
ils constatent que la voiture est garée
dans un petit lotissement en bas de la
cité justement que elle est pas elle
n'est pas abîmée qui manque des choses à
l'intérieur apparemment mais on l'ouvre
pas parce qu'on veut pas toucher on veut
laisser intact la voiture et il me
demande d'attendre parce que ils vont la
remorquer il emmener dans un garage pour
faire des prélèvements d'ADN et de et
d'empreinte je leur demande si on peut
pas la laisser sur place histoire de de
les prendre en flagrant délit parce
qu'il y a de grandes chances pour qu'il
ait laissé là et revenir ensuite voir si
personne l'a bougé pour la récupérer
mais m'explique que c'est pas les autres
qu'ils ont reçu donc c'est comme ça et
donc donc là toi tu as jamais su qui
t'avais volé la voiture moi je rentre le
lendemain on m'appelle on me demande de
venir au garage et donc d'ouvrir la
voiture pour que ils puissent faire les
en prendre des empreintes ça dure 10
minutes et donc là je réalise qu'en fait
ça aurait pu être pris n'importe où
n'importe quand que c'était vite fait
bien fait et que on a on a raté
l'occasion de les prendre en flagrant
délit donc je récupère la voiture je
paye les frais de gardiennage et de
remorquage pour rien en soi et je ramène
la voiture enfin je vais chercher un
traceur j'achète un traceur je ramène la
voiture où elle était je cache le
traceur avec le folle espoir qui puisse
revenir sans avoir remarqué que pendant
24 heures elle avait disparu d'accord et
là rien
mais je l'ai laissé pendant deux
semaines ça a pas bougé donc j'ai décidé
que il était temps de la récupérer un
moment quand tu dis tu as dit ouais
j'aurais peut-être pas fait comme ça
maintenant quoi mais parce que si
j'avais su qu'ils allaient pas prendre
les choses en main comme comme je viens
de le décrire mais je l'aurais laissé
j'aurais acheté le traceur je l'aurais
planqué je l'aurais laissé moi-même et
j'aurais moi-même essayé de voir si elle
bougeait et après je sais pas ce que
j'aurais fait j'aurais peut-être appeler
la police à ce moment-là peut-être qu'on
aurait eu plus de chance de les coincer
Gilles Verdez bon d'abord ma solidarité
c'est un viol de votre intimité je sais
que ça a été très pénible pour vous et
alors il y en a qui alors qu'est-ce que
tu réponds à ceux qui disent que c'était
une mise en scène
à ceux qui disent que c'était une mise
en scène j'en ai vu certains il y a déjà
c'est qu'ils ont pas vu la vidéo parce
que on en est plein de on a tu te serais
familier on n'a pas besoin de ça
pour les peu de personnes qui nous
suivent on est des personnes intègres
qui disons les choses comme on les pense
quand ça nous plaît on le dit quand ça
nous plaît pas c'est pareil on a pas
besoin de se justifier pour la quelques
décisions que ce soit d'accord je pense
sincèrement que c'est malheureux mais
aujourd'hui les gens sont matrixés et
plus que ce qui critique que même donc
ceux qui pensent que ils sont regarde ce
qu'ils disent non bizarre des voleurs
qui gardent une voiture de ce type
dehors des policiers un peu bidon j'y
crois pas qu'est-ce que tu réponds c'est
long c'est que les films sont inspirés
de la de la vraie vie et donc oui en
effet il y a des choses qui peuvent
choquer parce que peut-être qu'ils ont
pas l'habitude de que ça se passe comme
ça mais en effet quand on le contraire
quand on est dans la vraie vie ça peut
arriver c'est peut-être le contraire
souvent tu prends une voiture et tu la
laisses dans un endroit pour savoir si
elle est pas tracée c'est ça ça sert à
rien d'aller faire les 400 coups de la
revente si après la voiture elle est
tracée donc ne fait qu'il allait cela
toi tu voulais mettre tu as mis un
traceur dessus eux c'est ce qu'il
voulait savoir tu es venu la chercher la
voiture bah c'est plus la peine d'y
toucher puisque tu l'as retrouvé si elle
était pas retrouvé elle serait partie à
l'étranger après ça dépend moi je pense
sincèrement que c'était pas des pros
passer des 600 la voiture elle aurait
même pas été garée elle serait déjà
parti au pays de l'Est ou n'importe où
ailleurs maintenant oui en effet je
pense sincèrement qu'elle a été mis de
côté pour savoir si elle allait bouger
ou pas pour ça c'est un traceur dessus
mais moi ce qui me gêne Jonathan dans
votre démarche d'abord c'est très
dangereux vous le savez très bien et les
policiers volontiers j'en suis sûr vous
pouvez pas être policier en 14 vous-même
et d'autre part il y a des procédures
les policiers ils ont leur méthode trop
longue pour vous trop lente mais c'est
leur manière de bosser et là vous vous
êtes pris pour un policier à la place de
la police moi ça me gêne j'avoue
connaissant je n'ai pas compris que
délibérément vous placez hors la loi
comme ça vraiment des voitures volées tu
crois que les policiers ils vont courir
après toutes les voitures volées il y a
des procédures 30 jours la voiture sur
la récupère pas tu touches l'Argus de la
voiture et il te rembourse mais je vais
les assurances je vais je crois pas que
les policiers ils vont courir après
toutes les voitures volées ils ont autre
chose à de répondre
les procédures il y en a les prélever
les prélèvements d'empreintes et d'ADN
ça prend entre 6 et 8 mois pour avoir
des retour la voiture elle a le temps
déjà de faire le tour du monde ensuite
contrairement à ce que vous pensez les
policiers bon pas officiellement mais
mon clairement dit que parfois il vaut
peut-être mieux faire juste soi-même ça
vient de la parole d'un policier parce
qu'il sait très bien que malheureusement
il est piedmanié et que parfois ils
peuvent pas parce que ils ont pas le
temps ils ont pas les effectifs et
eux-mêmes le déplore maintenant
j'entends ce que vous me dites mais
personnellement j'avais le choix soit de
rester chez moi et d'attendre que ça se
passe et que rien ne se passe soit de
prendre le devant et d'avoir un tout
petit peu de chance de de me faire
justice moi-même
mais justement moi j'ai une question
c'est que si tu étais tombé nez année
avant ces personnes qu'est-ce que tu
aurais fait alors je l'ai pas vécu la
situation mais est-ce que tu cherchais
au final à avoir cette situation
Jonathan il a dit qu'il cherchait
d'abord
vous expliquer dans votre vidéo que vous
avez fait les les caves etc j'ai trouvé
tout de suite si si tentez que vous vous
l'ayez fait à ce moment-là et que vous
tombez nez à nez sur eux et que ce ne
sont pas des gentils vous rajoutez du
problème non seulement pour vous mais
aussi pour les policiers qui devaient de
moi
la violence je dois prendre pas mais je
vis dans la vraie vie je suis pas dans
dans les toupie on vous et moi en vie
des choses quand on sent ce viol de
l'intimité on réagit comme on peut si
vous l'aviez vécu vous auriez été en
colère si vous avez eu l'occasion
dans un parking mais c'est pas moi qui
l'ai retrouvé sur les policiers
et elle a été elle a été volée elle a
été retrouvée 300 ans plus tard
ok voilà être au courant et agir c'est
pas pareil fais gaffe parce que
c'est un bon ami donc non non mais c'est
vrai donc voilà
il m'écrit voilà il dit quoi le monsieur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'impression qu'on veut presque
protéger les cambriolets en fait faut
pas être trop violent avec eux
des cambrioleurs là en l'occurrence
monsieur il s'est fait voler sa voiture
on sait très bien que si il fait une
démarche classique il ne la retrouvera
pas il y a une autre forme d'injustice
je trouve dans les cambriolages c'est
qu'on ne sait jamais qui l'a fait et on
le sait plus jamais ça l'enquête après
c'est terminé on retrouve jamais c'est
bien et en plus on sait pas qu'il a fait
donc c'est normal qu'il veut sur
justifier en plus il le fait sans
violence et moi la question que je vais
vous poser c'est est-ce que ça vous a
donné envie de continuer l'enquête et de
récupérer peut-être d'autres choses et
savoir qui a fait ça on n'a pas tout
montré on a montré ce qu'on pouvait
montrer parce que Ben l'histoire de la
voiture se terminait mais je me suis pas
arrêté là j'ai fait le tour de tout le
trajet j'ai récupéré les caméras de
surveillance de tout le voisinage et oui
en effet on continue je lâche pas la
faire on a des bonnes pistes et pour
être très franc ce qu'on parlait de la
police parce qu'il y a pas que des
connards dans la police
justement qui a été vraiment touché et
qui veut nous aider et qui fait de
manière informelle parce que justement
en passant par le canal formel et
classique ben ça prend une plante
l'enquête n'a même pas été attribué j'ai
même pas une nouvelle de l'enquêteur un
autre logiciel j'ai un autre WhatsApp de
la police finalement vous avez dit quoi
vous avez perdu beaucoup de trucs
d'accord ils ont gardé que ce qui était
localisable je sais pas comment ils ont
fait pour le savoir et après concernant
la voiture ils ont pris ce qu'il y avait
dedans aussi et voilà quoi ils ont pris
les affaires impersonnelles les bijoux
les sacs même de mon fils pour gérer
justement vous êtes pas vexé parce
qu'ils ont jeté la moitié à la poubelle
c'était de la merde
[Rires]
j'étais prévenu
comme ça en mettant en scène tout en
expliquant sur le plateau de ça vous
avez pas peur justement de représailles
imaginons qu'il soit une bande organisée
et ils vont ils vont peut-être vous
chercher après des Muses et ça vous êtes
habillé
on a décidé de pas avoir peur et
maintenant ni pour votre fan ni pour
votre bébé on a mis un système d'alarme
en place à chaque fois que je pars et
ben les gens sont prévenus on a décidé
de partir même peut-être à l'étranger
pour être franc parce que ce qui nous
gêne c'est que c'était ciblé c'est pas
juste que c'est un cambriolage classique
voilà c'est que c'était nous et que si
on sait pas que c'est nous qui vivons là
c'est impossible de savoir qu'il y a ce
qu'il y a ici tu as une autre solution
c'est quoi tu mets Daniel Moreau de se
mettre dans la maison
[Rires]
il a dit la phrase tout à l'heure vous
vivez pas dans la vraie vie et lui vit
dans la vraie vie et il prend il prend
les choses en main si je veux dire
n'importe quoi et je vis dans la vraie
vie ma voiture
dans une banlieue j'ai pas pour eux
j'ai pas pour autant pris ma voiture en
prenant des risques et en donnant encore
peut-être plus de plus de travail aux
policiers qui aurait peut-être été me
retrouver dans un état dans un groupe
passé toute une journée à chercher sa
voiture tant mieux il a le temps pour
chercher une voiture il l'a trouvé tant
mieux mais je trouve que c'est risqué
parce qu'il a un enfant parce qu'il sait
pas sur qui va tomber et si on le passe
à tabac les premières personnes qui va
appeler ce sera les connards ce sera les
filles
c'est ce que tu as dit donc c'est très
dangereux
dis pas que je les aurais appelé et je
ne dis pas même que si j'étais tombé sur
eux que je me serais fait justice
moi-même pour être en sur le moment je
pense que ça aurait été le cas mais
parce que je suis honnête mais moi aussi
mais je pense sincèrement si vous aurez
pas ça des gens mais j'aurais pas vous
aurez fait du mal vous auriez eu du mal
à vous retenir et attendre l'arrivée de
la police il faut être sincère il faut
pas faire non
hexagonie
quand tu as retrouvé ta voiture tu as
été mettre un traceur après moi je
l'aurais pas fait dès que j'ai retrouvé
la voiture j'ai retrouvé la voiture je
rentre chez moi
la voiture est à toi le temps de
reprogrammer les clés tu me dis qu'ils
vont pas revenir à la chercher alors moi
je trouve inadmissible je trouve
inadmissible ce qui a été dit sur le
plateau par Guillaume parce que ça c'est
dégueulasse le problème je vais vous
dire non c'était il y a deux minutes
j'ai pas digéré il dit il dit et Gilles
vous protéger les cambrioleurs c'est
l'inverse de ce qu'on fait simplement on
est légaliste et c'est pas bien de dire
ça parce que ça met dans la tête des
gens qu'on s'en fout qu'on est pas
répressif c'est pas du tout ça
c'est la loi rien que la loi mais la loi
monsieur mais oui mais vous vous levez
les bras maintenant
elle permet à notre système aujourd'hui
judiciaire d'être à la hauteur mais
c'est la loi c'est ça la question moi je
ne dis pas que je suis au dessus des
lois qui a dit que je faisais la loi
avant simplement que je donnais un petit
coup de ma police
mais c'est pas bien attends attends
attends attends
2 minutes s'il te plaît parce que là tu
dis un truc si vous êtes qui pour c'est
lui qui s'est fait voler non mais
n'importe quoi
toi mais toi toi Gilles et je te dis la
vérité tu pourrais trouver un gars chez
toi en train de tout prendre tu dis man
dépêche-toi parce que je dois aller
chercher à tout le monde
je ne sais pas comment tu t'appelles ami
mais je dois aller chercher pas tout
dans une demi-heure je peux voler
rapidement tout ça
et lui il lui demande ma dépose-moi avec
ma voiture
[Applaudissements]
de jurisprudence que vous avez fait il
faut quand même dire aux gens
aller chercher les gars
il a juste tourné pour trouver sa
voiture
et du coup il risque la dernière fois
moi on on m'a volé ce que j'ai de plus
cher c'est quoi votre voiture
je suis parti j'ai fait des tours je
l'ai retrouvé
dans les choux la vérité c'est que je
savais à quoi je m'exposais je savais
aussi qu'elle était mes limites je sais
que j'ai une famille maintenant faire
attention je fais pas n'importe quoi et
quand je fais une vidéo YouTube où
explique ce qu'on fait j'explique aussi
que j'invite pas les jeunes à faire la
même chose par contre je mets les choses
claires sur la table et oui aujourd'hui
j'ai malheureusement pas le temps
d'attendre que les choses ne se fassent
pas non mais contrairement à ce que dit
Guillaume notre discours il nous a donné
la parole je le prends parce que
Guillaume m'attaqué aussi donc d'abord
et puis après oui mes meilleurs amis et
tu dis n'importe quoi mais déjà la
manière dont il agit lui donne raison
puisqu'il a retrouvé sa voiture et
ensuite pourquoi se faire justice
soi-même ce serait nécessairement
s'opposer à la police on peut collaborer
avec la police
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait violent il a
juste de apporter des informations qui
ont permis de retrouver la voiture quel
est le problème ça peut mal c'est pas
mal
on dit pas que c'est formidable ce qu'on
fait les les voleurs on dit que lui il
s'est mis en danger et moi mère de
famille je préfère dire tu t'es mis en
danger et j'ai pas envie que mon fils ou
les enfants de ceux qui nous regardent
fassent la même chose que Monsieur et
qu'après ils disent ah mais j'avais vu
dans TPMP le garçon il a fait ça moi mon
fils il a fait mal et c'est pris une
bastos donc je préfère
aussi réaliser que aujourd'hui
malheureusement quand il nous arrive de
se faire violer notre intimité de se
faire cambrioler parce qu'il y en a la
peine
les cambrioleurs je sais pas le terme
adéquat mais il se sentent en sécurité
et capable de tout parce qu'ils ont
l'impression qu'on va jamais les
attraper ça c'est la vérité